[Musique]
et
elisabeth de feydeau bonjour loge à
véronique merci d'être sur le plateau de
tv soixante dix huit pour ce vip
philippe leclercq bonjour et merci aussi
d'être là nous où vous êtes tous les
deux vous avez une action commune qui va
bientôt avoir lieu en octobre
le jeu de 5 d'ailleurs je moi au common
alors n'y a pas d' adresser une adresse
ses passages de l'agencé c'est l'endroit
où sont tous les antiquaires je veux du
voyage tout voilà c'est l'endroit où se
trouvent les antiquaires et les galeries
du quartier notre dame
voilà deux à versailles voilà nous
voyons la fiche d'ailleurs et il trouve
que tous les ans c'est gai luron
d'antiquaires font une fête et avec un
thème différent à chaque fois avec un
parrain ou une marraine différent à
chaque fois
et cette année le thème étant le parfum
d'où le titre les antiquaires ont du nez
des antiquaires ou choisit bien
évidemment qui d'autre elisabeth de
feydeau de grandes spécialistes parfum
que nous connaissons déjà et qui donc
vous allez parrainer donc ce set pas
dans sa vallée travers cette ba et des
mois c'est la manifestation cette
manifestation voilà ce que j'allais
faire à les abattre alors déjà je suis
très très heureuse d'avoir été choisie
comme marraine maintenant le voilà
invité d'honneur comme on dit c'est un
endroit que j'adore
voilà dans versailles c'est vraiment un
mais lieu de promenade favoris parce que
d'abord c'est très joli c'est hors du
temps il ya plus de voitures tout son
cachet s'est caché c'est vraiment une
pépite dans versailles
et puis on y trouve justement des
pépites au travers de toutes ces
galeries ses antiquaires et je dirai ce
qui est aussi sympathique c'est qu'on
n'a pas besoin d'être milliardaire pour
y aller si vous voulez vous dit trouver
aussi des petites pièces mais tellement
incroyable et on voulait raconter tout
ça donc moi j'adore j'adore aller me
promener j'y rêve comme chez vous oui
enfin comme chez moi t'es pas mais
presque
mais oui j'aime beaucoup beaucoup ce
lieu d'accord mais voilà c'est un vrai
lieu de vie
certes ils vont vous connais donc vous
êtes spéciale du parfum vous êtes
écrivain créatrice de bougies parfumées
conseils pour de grandes marques etc
mais vous fiez plus clair qui êtes vous
et était vraiment je suis anti kir
depuis 1982 la barre parce que j'étais
l'un des premiers après les brocanteurs
bien sûr l'élément je me suis installé
là bas avec un deux trois magasins donc
voilà je m'amuse toujours autant de
passion
à exercer mon métier d'antiquaire
d'experts d'abord et c'est lisais dans
un château dans tout ce qui est 18e
c'est pour sa 7ème une exposition sur
les consoles puisque je présente une
quinzaine de concerts et parler de dieu
qui va sauver la maintenant sur les
cessions et aux concerts une console wii
une quinzaine d'époque régence oui 15 et
16 passes assez important sécu alors
regardez nous avons l'écran différents
visuels qui vont passer alors celui ci
par exemple qu'est ce qu'être qu'on voit
là on voit surtout des du mobilier de
chez alexandre et la passion de tom qui
se situe en fait dans le passage de la
geôle
voilà mais c'est justement mais les os
les deux suspects on s'associe très bien
et à droite on a plutôt une une console
wii 15 avec un miroir d'époque régence
voilà ce que je peux dire sur ce plateau
très bien alors là bah tiens voilà
d'autres là on est plus dans la haute
époque haute époque sévère d'été pour la
haute époque c'est tout ce qu'ils voient
c'est tout ce qui est 16ème 17ème siècle
voire agents bien sûr et là on est
on situe plutôt chez laurence hélie qui
est entier car depuis longtemps
spécialisé dans tout ce qui se situe r
tout ça d'accord mais voilà qui dans le
carré des antiquaires
là vous arrivez sur mes fameuses
consoles puisque j'ai présenté et noir
perdent console en boîte dorée qui sont
vraiment superbes je me suis un petit
peu amusé à les mettre les unes sur les
autres
mais c'est donc ça c'est sûr les fonds
de boiseries que parce que je joue aussi
notre activité puisque je fais tout ce
qui est boiseries bibliothèque sur
mesure donc je leur ai présenté sur un
fond de boiseries très bien alors
concrètement donc la fête d'automne des
antilles cabalor voilà d'autres flacons
et oui flacons de parfum la colle pas
faim c'est un peu le thème de la fête
qui sont haussières j'imagine oui cela
il semble être anciens effectivement en
verre et cristal
bon c'est voilà 17e 18e ça valait donc
ça démarre le 5 octobre jeudi soir voilà
ça quand iker finalement ouvre son sa
boutique où ces galeries
ok briques oui chacun fait un cocktail à
l'intérieur de son magasin il voulait ou
en extérieur jeu kid raid quand même une
très grosse clientèle puisque on en voit
quand même un certain nombre de cartons
d'invitation
oui et donc il ya aussi bien des clients
qui viennent de province que tu
fabriques de faim voilà donc ces
traîtres
oui il était très long commence à 19h et
qui finissent généralement plutôt à 23
heures voire plus d'accord très bien
alors donc avec ce fameux thème du
parfum quel est votre rôle alors
elisabeth tout ce que vous allez faire
plus que d'être la marraine vous avez
vous avez qu'est ce que vous avez fait
raconté mois alors au delà de la soirée
au électivement j'ai organisé un jeu de
piste olfactif dans le quartier de la
joule qui va être lancée le jeudi soir
et qui dure deux mois
à l'issue il y à un tirage au sort avec
des lots à gagner alors pas un lot de
consolation face à nantes 1 mais voilà
quelques lots sympathiques à gagner et
ce jeu de piste olfactif il va falloir
aller se promener donc dans le quartier
de la geôle les vendredi samedi dimanche
qui sont légers ouverture et il ya un
petit flyer a récupéré avec des
questions qui vous sont posées sur le
thème des parfums à versailles et chaque
lieu qui sera déterminant qu'est des
terminaisons slayer pas rose avait voilà
vous avez une carte si vous voulez qui
vous est proposée vous allez chez un
antiquaire qui ont la solution qui ont
la réponse
et une fois que vous avez répondu à
toutes les questions y en a 12 ans tous
d'accord pouvez les déposer votre
bulletin de jeu chez tourmaline et le
tirage au sort aura lieu donc à la fin
du mois de novembre le dernier jour de
la manifestation
voilà donc un jeu de piste olfactif où
on s'amuse on visite les différents
antiquaires on sent également des
parfums de versailles et à lire on
répond à des questions et bien en fait
je me suis amusé à recomposer des
parfums peu typique pour l'événement a
pour l'événement je me suis servi de ce
que j'avais déjà dans notre programme a
connection
bougies par exemple pape abonnement on
va vous demander pour qui il donne les
réponses à donner des réponses mais par
exemple si vous aviez chez philippe
leclerc qui veut avoir une des senteurs
et bien y aura une question qui portera
sur les bosquets alors savez ce que
santé les bosquets à versailles alors
peut-être que des personnes le savent
déjà
s'ils ne le savent pas ils vont chez
philippe leclerc ils sentent cette odeur
dont qui représentait bosquet à
versailles mais les bonnes odeurs 1
passe 1 voilà et et puis on vous propose
trois solutions et puis en lisant le
petit petit panneau qui sera chez
philippe leclerc vous avez la réponse et
voilà et ça c'est comme ça et vous avez
12.12 trame dans ce chapitre des femmes
et bien sûr ça peut être un jeu
absolument pour les enfants c'est tout à
fait amusant puis vous sentez vous
apprenez des choses et puis vous voyez
de très beaux objets chez tous ses
atours malines donc qui propose quel
genre de dandy quitté alors tourmaline
c'est bernie guthmann qui elle aussi
depuis plus de 30 ans est à la geôle et
les géologues et joaillières donc cinq
ans très très beaux bijoux neufs ou
d'occasion et là aussi vous vous régaler
les yeux
d'accord la bombe écoutez c'est une
super occasion pour les versaillais
connaissent eux les yvelinois peut-être
mot enfin pas tous et c'est vraiment une
belle occasion pour aller découvrir ce
lieu qui est juste magique c'est quand
vous disiez tout à l'heure mais les
abete on est hors du temps et
et puis aussi faut pas se laisser
effrayer par le côté ce maudit quitté
qu'elle red hat en a pour tous les goûts
même avis 15 et même un disque moins
génial pour les disques en crm de vinyle
alors vous elisabeth vous avez une
actualité toute chaude tout chaud de
toute fraîche c'est pareil à ses marrons
chauds isemar au chaud voilà ça sort
qu'en se lier progression de 5 octobre
le jour de la fête entre hasard si oui
qui fait bien les choses alors ça
s'appelle l'eau de rose de marie
antoinette et autres parfums voluptueux
de l'histoire avec une préface de notre
ami le duc de berne
voilà chez les stéphanois pour les
intimes pour les intimes
alors de quoi de quoi ça parle ce
nouveau livre est là c'est une galerie
de portraits way qui va de cléopâtre
jusqu'à la reine victoria la narratrice
sissi l'impératrice eugénie
alexandre le grand enfin bonne série de
personnages célèbres anneaux ya aussi
des robes napoléon 1er louis xiv et tout
est donc je fais leurs portraits avec un
prisme qui est celui évidemment des
parfums et de la beauté voilà la beauté
aussi on entre dans l'histoire un peu
par le petit trou de la serrure par les
intellos par les impôts la l'intimé etc
ouais je parle même d'henri iv et de
cette mine noces avec marie de médicis
parce que le parfum a joué un rôle assez
étonnant c'était un peu le trublion de
la faire mais voilà donc il ya des tas
de petites anecdotes autour du parfum et
qui permettent de dresser le portrait de
tous ces personnages célèbres qu'on
connaît bien
mais là on va les découvrir un petit peu
différemment d'accord j'essaie secret
voilà degré tes vêtements et quand vous
m'aviez dit les tickets les toc
c'était quoi la frappe déjà grand
personnel et secrets d'alcôves aussi
quelques petits secrets d'alcôve et
voilà voilà donc philippe leclercq
d'écouté merci beaucoup
on va venir découvrir votre magnifique
boutique galerie d'art voile à partir de
jeudi
jusqu'à 20 novembre et puis jusqu'au 26
novembre jusqu'au 26 novembre et heroes
cependant qu est-ce qu on peut voir
archives vont là je présente donc une
quinzaine de consoles et une réunion de
trois tric trac en fait d'époque 18e
déjà réduit ses amis des tas de jeux qui
peuvent former jeu d'échecs jeu de dames
aujourd'hui le mag amon aussi voilà tous
ces médias qui sont bas marie-antoinette
bien sûr des crabes mes yeux bon ok bah
écoute et merci beaucoup merci le bain
je dis oui et puis on attendra donc
venir jouer et gagner et gagner surtout
mon père de consoles wii il faudrait
renoncer pas à dépendre à plat les oui
voilà en photo voilà ayez du lille ou à
gagner donc c'est à bord et j'imagine
que c'est joli
voilà et puis moi je recommande ce joli
livre aussi merci voilà tout est joli
merci a bientot merci
il